what is happening reject nation I am the
trained the G and I am the station of
the J over top Awards here some pastry
honors whatever video you request we
must definitely do and put up on the
youtubes today comes from Gregory
Bullock
oh and hey why don't you guys join our
patreon page over there we do
what-what-what weekly Q&A s TV show
reaction watch longs for shows like
attack on Titan Fullmetal Alchemist
Brotherhood my hero academia Riverdale
Gotham and supernatural and John does
music video coverage ok script
supervisor to be a continuity I notice
them all the time
to focus on just the placement of props
the props here are this folder that
clock on the shelf both of their
smoothies and this dragon thing let's
give these run this firm for 23 years
now and my credibility's on the line
here so great okay so the props have all
changed around supervisors changes like
this don't end up in the final cut looks
good did you have someone else go into
Joanne's fabrics for you while kind of
ex-wife looks like some of the problems
we already fixed are back but ideally
things that could be recurring issues
would be avoided from the start of
shooting for example it would have been
easier if both these guys had coffee
mugs so we couldn't see the changing
liquid levels like we can with the clear
smoothie house and then OS destroy
you must look out for great sunglasses
have these errors can occur if an actor
buries their performance between tapes
or maybe if filming takes place over
multiple days also the lawyers time
switch the two times the script
supervisors also have to pay attention
to dialogue the lawyer just said this
morning but we've already established
its 4:46 it's light outside so it can't
be 446 a.m. what he should say is why am
I only finding out this afternoon I used
to go by they know Sammy's don't sell
much better no I didn't think it was
pertinent information I had first shot
he picked it up with his left hand
and then the next he does it in his
right let's try again I didn't think it
was pertinent information that's better
it's important to note not just your
thoughts are but how actors interact
with them and keeping that consistent
between takes and setups come aside I
was trying to cover up my tracks all
right Sammy wank whatever you name is
you're gonna come clean with me I'm not
so sure I'm gonna be able to represent
you all right I might have brought my
Rottweiler into jo-ann's batteries and
she might have destroyed 17 rolls of
fabric but I did not set that place on
fire okay oh stop this shot here imagine
an invisible line running between two
characters okay I just want to keep the
camera
side of that line to maintain spacial
consistency notice the camera has always
been shooting from grace left side
because of this red is always seen on
the right side of our screen and the
lawyer on the left here suddenly we have
which makes it ears have swapped sides
of the screen let's fix this now
perfect also we already saw the great
smoke shot with the top page in the
folder this transition but now we
suddenly on the side of the desk and
there were no shots justifying this
shift
this is locking error let's get him back
where he belongs
there we go in case was what reshoots
are finding that yeah for Nixon Auto
really higher script supervisor DC no
glasses glasses which losses are there
to see but when we captured the wider
shot he's starting to his left
it's visor must track every move and
after maze to make sure they stay
consistent between takes and shot setups
one less it's alright
I hope it does Sammy I hope so I hope
that gave you a pretty good idea of the
things group supervisors have to look
out for and if you really want to put
your skills to the test we purposely
left a few other mistakes in the scene
you detach on your own let us know what
you smile this was it that I mean I do
that all the time
we're like watching movies wait stop go
get this this is here that's up there
that's out there that was here yeah and
every time I'm always like oh did you
catch something like I missed some kind
of huge plot need to oh oh yeah I mean
those are the fun things to pick out
because I mean unless they're so bad
that they're wrecking the movie it's
always funny to see where those Knicks
wind up what's interesting to me about
this mystery when looking at her credits
the script supervisor this is such an
underrated job who a script supervisor
does oh yeah this is Jaime mad
importance our last sketch that we put
together was for Avengers endgame on
that trailer reaction there's a major
error that occurs in the sketch have a
whole joke is that I'm in my boxers and
I run through the hallway and then in
the next scene the next moment I have
pants and I didn't notice that until
like oh [ __ ] we're done filming this
there's so many continuity errors that
always occurred that unless you're
looking for them you most likely won't
notice them yeah it's hard playing like
multiple heads when you're putting
together like just do something like a
sketch even that's like 5 to 10 minutes
long oh yeah you're acting but you're
also lighting things in your own so like
check it up on the scrim you got it you
got to make sure the editing will be
concise you have a lot of shots
themselves and her own movement
and the script supervisor is a really
hard job because especially for like it
all these films are Scorsese films and I
noticed and the scene was directed by I
notice Scorsese films often have at
least a few moments where I notice some
strong continuity errors what gives
Martha dad Martha suckish
or maybe it's the fact that Scorsese
really lets his actors have a lot of
freedom with movement and improvisation
yeah which is probably a [ __ ] for a
supervisor do you open yourself up yeah
all kinds of nolan films often have them
yes scripts things he likes to have a
lot of long tense take scenes that are
cutting back like something like this
where they're just coming back and forth
to in two different shots a lot of time
he doesn't have two cameras set up at
the same time or he's constantly pulling
from several different tastes and the
actors have such a big body language or
whatever I'll just notice things
constantly that's one of the hardest
thing I like I would love to see a movie
that's just a hundred percent script
supervisor then you also might lend
yourself to some really stiff
performances yes I imagine that's
perhaps the hardest thing I mean like
you want the coffee cups it's like as
long as you have somebody on hand to
keep filling those up you can work
around it but yeah it's like you never
know what's gonna come alive in one
angle versus a different angle and then
there's like the time you have to shoot
the rest of your day and all that stuff
and yeah you know certain things will
just inevitably slide through because of
the spontaneity of filmmaking like
watching one of these and then thinking
about all that just really drives home
the point that yeah this is like a job
to give to like a specific person and
this is the only thing that they do on
set is just to make sure that everything
is where and as it should be even in a
micro setting for us just trying to keep
track of these things while wearing
multiple hats it's so hard yeah cuz your
job is to police the little details you
know I feel like the biggest continuity
errors are actually that we've ever done
for ourselves or in that end games game
but it's like when you look at what the
when the time turns on it actually
changes time in the sketch like I'm
gonna clock to 702 it's just so hard to
track all this you know also like when
you're on our level you're like do I
want to reprogram my entire phone to get
these job like every single time we roll
I got to drag it back to seven what do
you think about a script supervisor you
usually do just think about like the
lines and making sure there is they're
following along with the script
yeah there's consistency in certain
movement or whatever but then a lot of
people don't take into account the like
what they call here prop continuity
usually the main thing I'll notice
I'll usually notice something like your
hands here and then the next one it's
long you know I always like those little
things more objects will move ever so
slightly or especially like the levels
of drinks is something that you really
stay yeah or like oh they reach for this
hand and now at the next shot it's a
different hand yeah I notice those
things all the time and that's because
we add at it you know what and the other
thing too is like if you're doing your
job as a script supervisor and you catch
something in one take and fix it for
another you never know if they'll just
go back and use that tape because maybe
something about it you're better you
know so like I gotta mention - that's
kind of a tricky job to get you're just
credits oh yeah I remember every
continuity here ever noticed but wasn't
really I don't know if this lady worked
on shutter island' I remember the scene
where was that doc but doctor is not Ben
Kingsley each other are max one see yeah
there's a scene where he's holding you
up
and I know that always noticed that this
is weird continuity errors I could
always stood out to me
and here let me just play it for you in
this scene just pay really close
attention to where Leo has the needle up
against his neck as if there's the shot
where it's on dr. nearing yeah where
it's like it's right up right up against
it cuts back to Leo it's other further
away or way gone there's a lot of
continuity and that and that's what I
means because there's probably a lot of
freedom that's happening with the actors
in that shot you know a lot more riled
up in seeped out shots and then in his
reverses where it's on Leo he seems a
little more like yeah because the thing
is with lighting and stuff it's hard to
like the ideal scenario would be you
have two cameras rolling at one time
which squares Scorsese has done and I
think for a Raging Bull my wife where do
you get your balls big enough there's
minute which is probably easier to get
down in a black-and-white movie but for
something like shutter island' like you
can't it's gonna be really hard to like
it's just so two shots you know yeah
well especially with architecture that
they have to deal with movie often times
it's like because of the freedom of
actor so I imagine being a script
supervisor
I think in those kinds of films were
like part of the performance River you
know we're all just kind of floating
Matt like it's gotta be the hardest
arguably to do but the benefit to with a
lot of moments like this in movies is if
you're so emotionally pulled in the
placement of camera is so important
because a lot of time it's like you
could have a master shot a wide frame
shot but the position of the lighting in
the lens is supposed to often draw your
eye to a certain thing so most people in
like this scene specifically are not
gonna look at DiCaprio behind the
shoulder they're gonna be focused on the
doctor so you're not even notice what's
going on with DiCaprio's hands in that
moment oh yeah well you know you might
just be in their faces and completely
miss that in your purse action yeah if
the if the performances are doing their
job yeah so I'm sure on set the script
supervisor did her job it's just there's
so many different takes two is again I
don't know where every script supervisor
hangs out but I got to imagine that no
matter what your perspective is you're
gonna be limited to your perspective
gonna be certain things that you just
can't see as well you got to watch the
page and the scene for the whole movie
like everything in the shot it's really
really difficult yeah of all the jobs
out there I really do think the script
supervisor czar under yeah is like
movies would probably look a lot more
messy without alright well thanks for
the request Gregory Bullock Gregory my
friend who identify with constantly it's
funny me I'm more than just the same
first name and the more I get to know
this artist who's actually working on
stars on reviews as well on camera which
I'm phone I hope you do soon it's fun
game know you man like you wonder how
that's in my ear because there's someone
who I very much identify with and I know
that you can have your own personal
emotional life struggles as well but do
know my friend that God is always with
you we like you a little bit we are fond
of the idea of you and it makes us happy
to know you exist I mean do we love you
insofar as we love people generally
and that includes you I love you like
the way I love my mom you know I I I
have to we are required I'm just kidding
buddy you know you know I love you bad
you want to take so much time to talk
with you if I didn't love you alright
buddy well hopefully one day we'll meet
in person when you come to California
away from that boring Boston town you
live in
anyway guys is there a scene that comes
to mind where you notice major
continuity errors comment below I gave
one example you give one subscribe to
the reject nation click notification
bells catch us on patreon bite
you